Okay let's recap where we are.
So we're talking strategies to do efficient CUDA programming.
And the first thing that we've talked about is using high arithmetic intensity--
trying to get your ratio of math operations to memory time
spent accessing memory as high as possible.
And so far we've been talking about the denominator.
The goal has been to minimize the time spent on memory.
Part of that is simply moving data to faster memory, if you're going to access it a lot.
Keeping in mind that, you know, the fastest memory of all is local--
local variables followed by shared memory, followed by global memory.
Another thing you can do is use coalesced global memory accesses.
So when you are accessing global memory, try to do it quickly.
And the trick there, is, adjacent threads are accessing a contiguous chunk of memory.
Usually, they're accessing adjacent memory locations.
Well what else do I need to think about when we're writing efficient CUDA programs?
In addition to striving for high arithmetic intensity, we also want to avoid thread divergence.
Let me explain what that means.
When parallel threads, like threads in our trusty thread block, do something different, we say they diverge.
So we had some code that looked like this in the kernel.
You're doing some stuff and you reach an if statement--if condition is true then execute some code.
Else executes another code, then you proceed.
If you think about a whole bunch of threads in a kernel executing this code,
all of these threads are going to get down here.
So these threads are going. They're going to hit this condition. They are all going to execute this condition.
And then some of those threads are going to take the if branch, some of them are to take the else branch.
So this thread proceeds, hits the condition, and then we'll see it takes the if branch.
Maybe this thread proceeds when it hits the condition, maybe it takes the else branch.
Perhaps this thread takes the else branch as well. And maybe this thread takes the if branch.
Okay, so these threads have diverged.
Of course, in this particular case, afterwards they're going to all proceed together again.
So this thread's going to keep on going, finish the if code.
This thread will keep on going, finish the if code.
These two threads will each keep proceeding and do the else code.
And it'll all converge again.
And you might notice that I tried to draw them
so that they kind of reassemble into the same order they were.
In fact, their thread IDs have never changed. Okay?
This is still thread 0, this is still thread 3, this is still thread 2--
sorry thread 1 and thread 2.
So the thread indexes don't change, it's just
the path that they're executing through the program is different.
So that's what divergence means.
This is thread divergence, threads that do different things.